Once the changes to the neutral pose have been saved to the DNA file, in order to bring those changes back into Unreal Engine, the head LODs will need to be exported as FBX files.
In this section, we will go over how to use the export FBX script from the examples folder to achieve this.
Let's return back to Maya and go through the steps.
In a new Maya scene, I have pasted the export FBX script in a new Python window.
Now, if we wish to use the modified DNA we generated from the previous section, in the DNA calibration folder, inside of the output folder, we will need to copy the modified DNA file.
Then, go over to the data folder and place this in the DNA files folder.
For this example, I will be using the DNA file named linafinal that was generated for the preset lina from the UnrealFest calibration script.
You can locate this DNA file in the source files folder of our course in the folder named linaunrealfest.
Now, the export FBX script will need a prepared body skeleton Maya file, which should be placed in the body folder inside of the data folder.
The body folder will automatically come with two prepared body files for Ada and Taro.
Ada uses the female medium normal body weight and the Maya file is named femskeleton.
Taro uses the male medium normal body weight and it's named mask-skeleton.
If your character uses either of these proportions, you can use these files instead of having to prepare one.
I have taken the prepared skeleton from the UnrealFest zip folder named lina-skeleton and have placed it in this folder.
This is for the female short underweight body proportion without the arms and the legs.
With the assets we will be using for this script in the data folder, let's configure the paths for this script.
In the script editor, on line 36, set the path of the root directory to point to the location of the DNA calibration folder
and replace a backward slash with a forward slash.
On line 45, add the name of the DNA file that will be used.
On line 58, configure the path of the body Maya file.
This is already directed to the body folder.
All you need to do is change this to the name of your body Maya file.
This script will create an output folder if one does not already exist and will place the exported fbx files in there.
With everything configured, select this entire script and execute it.
This will take some time to finish, so once it is done we will continue.
Now that the process has finished, inside of this Maya scene, we will see the last head LOD that an fbx has been created for, which is LOD 7.
Now let's review the steps we just covered before we move on.
Once we are finished making adjustments to the metahuman neutral pose and have saved the changes to the DNA file,
the next step is to export the head LODs as fbx in order to bring those assets along with the updated DNA file back into Unreal Engine.
To do this, we can use the export fbx script that can be found in the examples folder.
First, ensure you copy the modified DNA file that is added to the output folder after using the propagate changes from scene to DNA script and paste it in the DNA files folder.
In Maya, paste the script in a new Python window.
The next step will be to configure the paths.
We will need to configure the path for the root directory so that it points to the DNA calibration folder.
And just remember to replace the backward slash with the forward slash.
On line 45, the character name should have the name of the DNA file that will be used.
On line 58, assign the path to the prepared body Maya file.
As mentioned, the feminine and masculine skeletons in the body folder are for the medium normal body weight proportions.
Next, select the entire script and execute it.
This process will take a bit of time and once it is complete, all of the head LOD fbx files will be added to the output folder.
The final step is to assign material placeholders to the head geometry assets for each head LOD.
So, let's return to Maya and go over this.
Back inside of Maya, in the File Explorer output folder, we can see all of the LODs that were exported.
In this new Maya scene, I have added the head LOD 0 fbx.
Something to note is that this script does not create material placeholders for each of the head geometry assets.
When using the script, we will need to create new material placeholders for each of the head geometry assets
and use the same naming convention these assets have assigned inside of Unreal Engine.
I'm going to hide the joints for a moment.
Now, we can manually add a material. Select the head mesh, right click and select Create New Material.
Then repeat this for all of the head geometry assets and for all of the other LOD fbx files.
I have already created a material placeholder for every head geometry asset for this example,
so that as I go through each one, you can see the naming convention for each of these.
The head is named Shader Head Shader. This is the name for the teeth, the saliva, the eye left, the eye right,
the eye shell, the eyelashes, the eye edge and the cartilage.
Since this can be very time consuming, you can write a script to automate the creation, naming and assigning of these shaders.
The Unreal Fest calibration script has commands that you can use that will do this for you.
Now, before we move on, let's do a quick review of what we just covered.
If using the export fbx script, all of the head LODs and their assets will need material placeholders assigned.
Name each of the geometry assets with the same naming convention as they are labeled inside of Unreal Engine.
To do this manually, select the LOD0 head mesh, assign a new material to it and label it Shader Head Shader.
Something to note is that you can write scripts to automate the creation and naming of Lamberts to speed this process up.
Another option is to take the commands from the Unreal Fest calibration script that will create and name materials
for all of the head mesh geometry assets and LODs.
Now that we have gone through the process of using DNA calibration to make simple changes to the metahuman neutral pose
and save those changes to the DNA file and then export the head LODs,
the last step is to bring these assets back into Unreal Engine to finalize the rig.
As mentioned, we will be continuing this workflow in the metahuman DNA calibration and finalization course.
Now let's wrap up this course with some final recommendations and some tips and resources for you to use.